i'm wearing a muscle shirt that says
kome kaka
at the formal dinner that means eat [ __ ]
and i walk i walk into the formal dinner
and my commodity just says
looking at my wife says come commander
don't look now but he's back
and
everybody's in tuxedos and former wear
and i walk in wearing a comedy
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
sport sporting paul you know george is
oh i'm sure he's around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez george
lopez oh my god omg omg
[Music]
attention listeners across the galaxy
all the way from australia to houston do
we have a pew problem houston we have a
pew problem hey
so
manscape you know what manscape is right
i know what man's so manscaping these
dudes
have cleared you for take up it's a
fourth generation it's a brand new mower
4.0 you kick your pubes to the next
planet what planet is that that's a long
ways away wherever it is
that's known as mars
planet i like that with the performance
package they're 4.0 so the orbit in your
pants will feel like it has zero gravity
because when you use the best tools for
your palito down there and your vitos
you are the leaders in male grooming
take it from a friend of mine who called
me and said
that he's never felt
safer down there
less payloads you know it's almost like
would you let your house
grow with all the bushes so nobody could
see the house no you'd want to be clean
right you'd want it to be clean topiary
a little monitor like a little doll or
something that dolphin
there's ladies that do their their
pubes in a heart shape i think about
those should do like an arrow
or flames yeah flames you gotta go
flames you know there you go like wow
you're going so fast down there that's
so join the 2 million worldwide who
trust manscape and get your rocket ready
for takeoff by going to manscape.com for
20 off of free shipping with code omg
high that's a lot that's good that's get
your weather taken care of and you get
20 off so your pedals will probably be
like 75 off but then you'll be doing it
with 20 off of the of the price
and if you cut flames you'll do it even
faster and if you cut flames i'm gonna
complain
in mine
how did austin do man good huh good yeah
no people were uh so i did the thing
you're never supposed to do and i was
reading youtube comments and all sorts
of things for everybody they're all no
they're all very popular [ __ ] people
hate me
i've been around too long to be [ __ ]
like alex listen if you hate me
i mean
i don't want to tell you i mean you're
more i mean haters of you know if they
hate you why they listening to this
podcast
you want to read some of the comments
that they say
i don't know why i don't you know i
don't know what it is man like what how
would it be if all of this hate was
actually
comments about
good comments about saying hey you know
what gil i love listening to you on that
podcast and i i think it's great you've
been married such a long time
and you know you and george have a great
relationship together it's interesting
to see it grow instead of saying like
you don't need that [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] guild you can have your own
[ __ ] podcast with crime you don't
need that [ __ ] old butoh right there
that was sent from i sent that one
you know
the worst verified account the worst one
i got well it was actually an instagram
message and i just laughed at it and
somebody said
how come you're alive how come you're
not dead instead of richard good god he
should be alive and you should be dead
why's that who thinks that who thinks
that the [ __ ] richard ramirez the
night stalker should be alive one of us
remember the detective should be dead
one of his fan members
and i just laughed you know what these
guys whoever that fan member is if
you're richard ramirez fan i don't know
god bless you but what do you make for
dinner like a [ __ ]
cauldron of [ __ ] bats
that's what kind of [ __ ] dead
hummingbirds and a [ __ ] stew with
some potatoes like you know that kudos
they work
they probably work at a place that
[ __ ] maybe they
they you know like not like austin
because not all of his were black but
you know they figured they paint their
fingernails and they live in this false
[ __ ] dark world that they
create in their own mind
i just laughed i didn't care
it doesn't i mean
what's sad to think is that this is
what's in people's hearts i mean trump
didn't do it it's that's in people's
hearts oh yeah it definitely drew it out
i mean he drew it out and made it okay
to do it in public yeah you know and and
even like the right
you know send me messages or whatever
they're dicks you know
you're getting dick cops holding their
dicks i mean is that really you're a cop
is that really wrong
is it wrong i send an ig message when
you're holding this i mean
with the little [ __ ] like the little
umbrella like the lidsville thing you
know remember elizabeth the from the
football hat like that
that [ __ ] company i look at it i
don't give two shits about those people
i'm 71 years old i've made it this far
without them i don't need them now
they're not going to set me back i've
had way too much fun in my life and i'm
having more fun today than i've had in
years that's what i'm saying that's good
i mean that's really living well is the
best revenge we're all we're all going
to go yeah and i've seen a lot of people
that have gone already you know i think
about myself at 60 and i think about
you know seeing my grandmother and
thinking in the car
i mean i don't know if i can't i can't
really remember i didn't hate her but
she was you know everybody's [ __ ]
grandma was cold what the [ __ ]
right
that mean yeah
my wife already knows that i still make
fun of her
you know what i mean like she told you
that i mean
and then you snapped her out of it i
think you i think you when you said hey
what if i go to vietnam and i don't come
back yeah we snapped her out of it when
she probably said
she hated me in the beginning she didn't
want that to happen once i became a good
guy then she loved me then i became ego
but you were the same guy yeah i hadn't
changed i still haven't changed i'm
still the same guy i used to make fun of
her then i still make fun of her today
and my wife just saw all my wife ever
says leave her alone
how long did she how old did she live to
be
she was 93. wow maybe 90 maybe even 95.
she was 95. like a year and a half ago
yeah she died uh two years ago
oh my god she lived a long time yeah oh
she did
you know what she saw she got to see
you create this family and your wife
be married
got to see she lived with us the last
six and a half years of her life no
kidding
she got it first hand
got to see she lived with us the last
six and a half years of her life
yeah
in the same house right shouldn't get
any bigger in the same house i wasn't
living alone much she was there you know
i could tell you what time of day it was
by what was on tv she'd sit oh my gosh
same place i could tell you what was
happening
and the only show
that i used to sit down and watch with
her was two and a half men i had never
seen this show until she started i loved
it
how did she watch it she's watching two
and a half minutes two and a half men
that's great i i didn't have at the
there for a while
uh directv didn't have uh
sportsnet la
them and spectrum were
they were so yeah and my swag and i
would sit there and say are we going to
watch the divers today i said no they're
not on tv well why not we don't have
that station i had directv at the time
and finally i just told my wife you know
what's just easier so i got i had direct
i went ahead and ordered spectrum
television just so she could watch the
dodgers on tv you know that's
that's that's incredible
you ever when you were growing up was it
ever so hot in your house that you had
to watch tv in the front yard so we
didn't have we only had one tv is either
i mean just take it to the front yard no
it just stood inside it used to be so
[ __ ] hot yeah my grandmother's house
went outside it wasn't to watch tv then
it was the endless guys with the fellows
with the friends
kids playing
i lived in a cul-de-sac so so did i you
could watch this
we had a baseball diamond you did two
yeah
did you we had a baseball diamond [ __ ]
honky paint it on the cul-de-sac oh yeah
poor people lived in cul-de-sac so the
other wonderful white people cars
see you later
i'll be coming back around tonight
nobody ever [ __ ] got lost in our
neighborhood you know
oh you're doing it oh come on let's see
i'll take that back this is the horvath
cul-de-sac the horror
the horror boy
my daughter lives in the house with her
family in the same house that i grew up
in
yeah that's that's
that's badass huh yeah man what are we
talking about today well we're we're
guest-less just uh just us on our
thoughts i mean we obviously have yeah
gail did we talked to bobby lee
bobby i haven't spoken to them yet i'm
going to get them up about bringing them
back on yeah yeah no i think there's uh
but also let's thank the let's thank the
sponsors i mean that that uh the food
what was the food one that that they
gave me the food in the house was
awesome uh i think that one's hellofresh
and then we've got a pre preview we've
got more uh more than what else
landscape hey
i don't listen that's a very personal
question and when condition your wheels
are in but
manscape the 4.0 what are they they have
some crazy name right oh yeah the
eliminator what's it called this is uh
this is the uh picture that's
eliminating hair the lawnmower 4.0 the
lawnmower 4.0 yeah and this is this
one's all space themed so it's talking
about kick your pubes to the next planet
you know
i've never tried it yeah
they did when i had a surgery you know
they they shouldn't have that was one of
my jokes the only time you trimmed your
hair is when you got your appendix taken
out the uh uh but also
one time there was a
a woman coming over to see me and i was
in in houston
allegedly and i and i shaved my my
pedals and i nicked myself down there
and then she put her hand down there she
was like oh my god and i was bleeding
and she took off in horror i just told
her you should've just told her it was
your period
yeah i should have said
i'm on my period
maybe there's some confusion well that's
an exclamation point down here
yeah you know those things are all uh
people are crazy just scrolling through
instagram
it's nice it's not it's not a lot of
people used to used to have to work hard
to see a girl school
you know sometimes you fell off the
ladder
you could risk about risk bodily harm
remember there was like keeping time i
can't be i can't be talking about that
stuff too you know you could jack up and
get on the under on the siding of the
house then you'd have to go back and
chip it off you'd be like before dna
you know you could you could fire one
off on someone's window
i use a story yeah then you can use a
story to get a kite remember when i
heard that they're
about getting that fear in your eyes and
looking i had a case right there in east
l.a where some guy got in a car with
some girls cruising on whittier
boulevard and then he stuck a gun and it
was two girls and a guy he stuck a gun
in the side of the ribs and said come on
we're going to party now this okay he
said hey come here kiss me i want you to
kiss me and then the driver said hey if
we're going to party let's stop and get
something to drink
so he pulled in the liquor store and he
just said okay but i'm going with you
and if you say anything if you do
anything he says you're dead so he gets
off the car and he goes with her and it
just so happened that a police car black
and white
pulled into the kerb lane because
they're going to turn right she screamed
they jumped out they got him they
got the gun they got everything he went
to jail
so i get the case the next day
that night a night detective talked to
him and sent him down to cj downward
for uh down what's he doing between a
night to take him out a day detective
dave detectives work days nights work
nights but the guy at night doesn't want
to do [ __ ] well he he he takes care of
all the arrestees that come in on the
night shift
he may do a preliminary interview just
get a few facts the day dick is the one
that's going to handle the case it's
going to be my case okay so he he
interviewed i i come in
that detective had to go to court he saw
me say by the way i interviewed your guy
last night from the kidnapping with no
[ __ ] kidnap a couple of tramps picked
them up
it was an inoperative starter pistol
that's all it was
like for races yes oh wow
i said all right
so i looked it looked like a real gun
you know but it was just a starter
pistol and it wasn't operative at that
so i said i took my partner i said come
on let's go i want to go talk to this
guy
so i went down and i talked to him and i
said hey partner you know you've already
been admonished and i knew his brother
because i'd handled his brother a few
times i said hey you know i know your
brother okay come on i want to talk to
you but i know the guys that bought
advisory rights last night
i want to talk to you about us more
because this case was fascinating to me
and i said but
you got to waive your rights again
and he said he agreed i read him his
rights he waved and i said okay wow so
you read him the rights and says
anything you say yes do you understand
the rights he said yes yes and then he
said i wave him and i'll talk to you he
was willing to talk to me because he
thought i was the ideas i was good to
the family and he trusted me he never
should have trusted me wow so i talked
to him and i said before we really get
in i got to tell you something
i was reading the report where you got
the gun and you stuck it in the side of
your ribs and you know what but by the
grace of god the only reason i'm here
today
is because somebody helped me i said
because when i was a kid i was a traviso
and i used i was a peeping tom
and i used to go around at night and
look in windows
i said and i'd start whacking off he
says and then just before i busted a nut
i tap on the window because i wanted to
see him scream wow
i said and that got my nut
and i said and when i'm looking at this
case where you stuck the gun in there
and made her kiss you that reminded me
when i was a peeping tom because that's
why you were doing it he looks at me
says yeah
that's why i did it i knew the gun
wasn't working but that's why i did
today
i got off on that [ __ ]
got to finally on the case for
kidnapping and a few other charges
because he copped out because
what i learned from or no the look of
fear and i'd seen it i just wanted to
try it
officially i was never a peeping tom
but
i used that
to get him to cop out
i never thought about tapping on the
window though because i was just
satisfied just to be
throwing on the side of the house right
there
eye contact too risky like nachos and
leaves with a little creme on top
god damn
[Laughter]
so what's the what's the uh
i was saying psychology what's the
psychology of a dude in the park
opening his jacket or peeping tom
and doing that on the street or a car
drives by the guys is is
jacking off as a car drives by the lady
sees him he wants to see the look the
startledness of of the victim the victim
is whoever he's flashing that's right if
she if she were if it were let's just
say forsaken bargains it's a she
if he opened up his coat and there's his
dick and he she looked at him and said
is that all you got
that ain't [ __ ] that's a lit that's not
even a dick that's a beepy
he'd cover up a leaf you never want to
hear that
that he'd cover up and leave he didn't
get the effect he wanted she's
belittling him now it's in his court
he's out of there right he didn't scare
her he didn't bother her
and then soon as he's gone
then she may think oh [ __ ] what did he
do you know call a cop to whatever but
her first instincts were you know is
that all you got laugh at him somebody
with street mocs he would do that
that's a tough thing to do though
no but that person is a non is the
peeping time a non-threatening person
most of them are not most right yeah but
that guy did all that did it matter that
it was a starter gun the person doesn't
know it's a starter gun no no no it
doesn't matter not to the victim for
for all intents and purposes on this
case it was a real gun right
does that change does that ever affect
it if it is like an actual you know a
real pistol versus starter pistol back
then that wouldn't have
you know when you had a kidnapping use a
gun
the gun would be an enhancement
this is not an operable gun so it
wouldn't be an enhancement why do people
kidnap other people and it's usually
somebody that people know right
not say i'll say somebody become fixated
on somebody i really don't know people
kidnap
pedophilia
for kids that's easy that's that's
pedophilia adults it's usually because
of
they either want to rape you know in
case of female you know kidnap and rape
some kind of sexual deviate or
kidnap for ransom or i'm pissed off i'm
angry just like this guy that just got
filed on he drove his uh
the mother of his children three kids in
the back seat she's in the front seat
they'd been in a fight he got her
through in the car and drove up the
up the off ramp
on the freeway
and she got killed the kids got injured
and he got taken into custody
it was just a few days ago oh is this
was this out here yeah like the reptil
like he thought his kids had like
reptilian dna or some crazy no that was
that was another guy that was another
case that was another one what's up with
the white dudes they think that that was
a white guy that got coming back from it
got caught in mexico i believe oh really
but he his kids were over there what is
that though why do people think that
they're are there people with [ __ ]
reptilian
well i
i think that guy's been smoking too much
meth or either that or the guy was just
uh well some of that stuff
too and i don't i don't know which i
don't know what he's doing
but like it's at a certain point it's
like you know these billionaire
democrats running the world are also
like lizard people you know it gets into
that sort of territory i think that's
what it was what about that one that
they had the pizzagate were they where
they thought that
in was that in dc or yeah of some dc
jersey or somebody
that they thought that
they were running a pedophilia ring out
of this pizza parlor and this guy drives
down there with a loaded weapon goes in
there and tells the and pulls a weapon
on everybody right yeah and he says open
that door right there there's kids in
there and that guy's like
doc it's pizza dough there ain't kids in
there [ __ ] there's like supplies
like pizza sauce and dough
and he goes open it up and they open it
and it's a
storage place for the pizzas
and then when they took him out
the cops had him on the ground
one of the cops says can't believe how
stupid this [ __ ] guy is this guy's
like what the [ __ ] are you are you doing
what are you doing and he pretty much
said you know they were running the
pedophilia ring out of that pizza parlor
and the cop's face was like
what they're not
yeah they're not
and i had to save him he's not on the
ground i had to save them
it's like hey man they're not dude like
this none of that's in there i wonder if
you picked up any of those mattresses on
the way home
with a little the nachos on no the one
the commercial now looks like a big
piece of pizza
he says can i have it can i have it he
goes
oh the guy says yeah go ahead and take
it and then they show it really it's
just a mattress but he saw pepperoni
it's like a grubhub commercial or
something like that i think those are
those are some funny ones you guys order
grubhub and and uh postmates meals on
postmates
and what do i have what am i next door
what's mine uh what's mine what do you
think there's door dash
doors i use door dash oh you talking
about you're like i have my taxi thing
the george lopez tacos yeah i don't know
and all that stuff mexican soda the the
one that [ __ ] your teeth up like
everybody in mexico
not everybody likes cool but the ones
that look like uh [ __ ] canelo their
teeth
i just went to all the brown olive
browns i just went to the dentist this
morning got my teeth cleaned oh and
they're looking they're looking good
you can see the gleam even from here
you know a 60 year old man should you be
eating three bags of tootsie tootsie
rolls no
[ __ ] last weekend
i think i'm too old for that but but uh
i don't know if at any point it's
advised for you to eat three bags of two
year olds they're pretty good though man
oh yeah but a little wow like how long
would it take to get to know that
commercial
to get to the center of a tootsie roll
pop
oh yeah
one two three
three
the um
what about richard ramirez like
how significant was the finding that
um
the appointment card in that car oh very
important wasn't that it right yeah that
was that gave us the
information to
the dentist we got his x-rays we could
tell that he had problems with his teeth
he was going to be going back
so so he gets here he has problems with
teeth are bad like if you saw those
x-rays
in a lot of pain right [ __ ]
abscess and
abscess and crazy mouth and then
he said i gotta i gotta get some place
to look at these teeth right because
they were so bad he went into the place
right there in chinatown or something
guy looked at him
and then started treating him and
started treating them
and then
you guys said oh this guy's going to
come back
like his think they're so [ __ ] up he's
got a guy i got a hold of his x-ray the
doctor gave me a copy of his x-rays i
took him to a good a good buddy of mine
who grew up together bobby bersano who
was now a
dentist i took him to bobby said hey
bobby look at what can you tell me says
oh the guy's got an abscess he's going
to be back he's going to be in pain
and so and and richard was always a cash
paying customer
if you have any credit cards so you cash
paying
so that's when we stuck the guys inside
the uh
inside the dental office and they left
and
yeah an executive from my department
said this is a waste of money not coming
back
because we were paying them seven days a
week
12 hours a day they were getting
overtime they were getting fat
and he said pull them off put the alarm
in there
so lapd came and put the alarm in there
and it was nobody's fault
other than the executive from my
department that ordered my guys out of
there
the alarm didn't work the alarm didn't
work it was a malfunction that's all it
was malfunctioning alarm and was it like
an alarm that someone would trip or just
like how the doctor had to press the
button okay okay and the doctor did the
doctor did his
job law enforcement didn't do our job
you know he did more so when he pushed
the button it didn't nothing to connect
anywhere so yeah those guys would have
stayed in there which is which is the
old way of
yeah i mean not the old way but it was
an effective way to
to have somebody they couldn't call by
using the chair
yeah they couldn't call i didn't hear
somebody
oh no
no no call 9-1-1 he was given
instructions just hit the alarm they'll
come down
and because it's dangerous yeah
yeah not even like give him an extra hit
like laughing gas or something like that
just chill him out for a little while
plus it would have been difficult the
doctor was it was difficult to
understand
very thick accent
and so it would have been tough but
our guys would have we had two asian
guys in there they'd take care of
business
where did the appointment card come from
is that just recovered at the crime
scene when is that no in one of the cars
we tried to kidnap uh
kid up in the valley where he hit an
on-ramp
and the car got impounded we went back
to look and we found
this little plastic a little cheap
plastic case
and there was an appointment card in
there
and that's where we knew he had been to
the doctor wow that's what starts to to
crack it
the
but those things are the ones that
is make the best
they make the best
police work because it's done from
person to person yeah if you go in there
you trust yourself if you go in there
and i don't know you're in first of all
i think undercover is maybe the toughest
job
of police or is it
or
being a lady detective going out there
with your choncho out there but you're
still a police officer you can't be out
there where you [ __ ] finally out
there you're a [ __ ] law enforcement
huh yeah they they do it they have to
it's a job they don't do it anymore
though what about if a dude was if they
were looking for like andrew cunanan and
they said hey
what if graham was a detective you're a
good looking dude you're gonna go out
there dolphin shorts there's a nurse
bent over drinking water there's a
danger to the job they do what they're
called upon to do if we needed that we'd
done it in heartbeat
you know that that's just the nature of
the journey you know what we should do
we should get grant
and and dress them up like dolphin
shorts put them out there in the burbank
media center and see how long it takes
before the police go up and say hey can
we help you young man yeah cut shirt do
you need help sir a little like
some kiss little orange slices
like a little like number 88 but this
it's cut in half
i'll get my nails done i think there'd
be a crowd around them before the cops
got there
[Laughter]
but you know when uh
i i got uh i got fired from a job um
when i was in my early twenties
and a guy was undercover at that the
at my job so african-american dude was
pretending like it was a new hire and
stuff and
i
had some i was doing stand-ups i was
driving around so we had the we had
white i don't think it was
methamphetamine but with just whites the
pennies the cry out that's what these
guys
like white crosses
and i was you know going as far as i
could go
to perform and then still get back
and i would take the bennies in the
morning and then i remember
the guy gave you know the guy's like hey
what do you got you know you know it's
[ __ ] whatever
the undercover cop is yeah yeah and then
you know so i said you know i have these
things but can you get more and i said
yes like i couldn't get more i just said
yes yeah whatever i'm [ __ ] like ate
them
and he started like i was you know some
mastermind mastermind no [ __ ] and then
uh you know they got me and they got um
they got another guy but the other guy
was dealing they were dealing colt
on the night shift which in the early
80s that's
quite uh
not very uncreative pretty standard yeah
yeah i was just watching cocaine cowboys
the netflix documentary about miami the
ones with the all over the place down
there it was all over the place
and then it came here right there was
chicago
first time i saw cocaine was in the late
seventies just before i left patrol i
think that's when it was and that's when
he later that was the first time and
that's because i had an informant call
me a pearl man had just gotten picked up
sent to the joint behind the robbery and
she was very good friend and she's
called me hey he left some stuff back
here i said okay just go put it by the
budget we'll go by
see what it is
so i went by and here's this
uh plastic baggie with a bunch of powder
in it and it was cocaine
i had never seen cocaine before
that way nobody went to jail there's
nothing behind it it was his she left
the behaviors i just went out of the
house
and so
you don't know where to i was only
talking about it
yeah where it is or anything no that was
a long time when that was somebody
couldn't charge anybody with i mean you
could say hey it's in the [ __ ] garage
soldiers can no no we wrote
found narcotics and just nobody went to
jail behind it we just got it off the
street
and it was his and he was going to the
joint
that's pretty good though
i'm going to say
grant
i'm looking up there the shelf line of
cocaine
uh throw in the freezer you never tried
aaron man come over in my house
[Music]
grant get your give you a little short
save come on
yeah pool party we'll have him in there
yeah why somebody throw it off the roof
and they'll just land on land on this
it'll be snowing in los angeles yeah
but that that changed i think it that
changed a lot when it and then when it
went to crack or meth or whatever the
crack was bad in the early 80s you still
an officer then
well no i in 81 that's when i went to
homicide
so i'm working murders whenever we have
let's say it's a drug-related murder
first thing we do we get to murder the
body's mind but i need some intelligence
i need to learn more about this drug so
you get the guys from narcotics that's
how they work get them to help you out
get that let's go through the anatomy of
a drug murder okay let's say that guys
come in where would it come in like san
pedro or whatever so it's on the street
right
and
you go in there maybe you have 10 grand
you buy a kilo or something right
you're a pretty reliable source sure you
double check um
and then i take it and i sell it
wherever at work let's have a solid at
work and you come back
and you're still dealing with the same
dude can you trust that guy to get
another give him another 10 and get
another yeah you you trust them you you
get them and where the drug deals go bad
can you can it kind of
can a cause you know instinct is a
[ __ ] huge thing right like instinct
is a big deal sure i mean
people are in the car i was i was in the
car one time coming home i worked nights
and something told me this
i had a green light and something told
me to stop
and a band with his lights off went
through the intersection and if i would
have been going through i think it
probably would have killed me
like there's times that people don't
trust their instinct
there's times that people have gotten
off planes and said [ __ ] it i'm getting
off
and maybe the plane made it but that
person you couldn't tell that person
that they're
that they're not wrong that their
instinct is wrong sure yeah and with
drugs the person is selling to you
you're right
cocaine oh yeah yeah i think cocaine is
uh same thing with methamphetamine it
develops into paranoia people get
paranoid right
so
there comes the problem you don't know
if when you go to buy if that guy thinks
you're a rat
you know you don't know if it's gonna be
a drug rip-off okay i'm coming to buy
from you they know i've got money so
they're just gonna whack me right all in
the same
or here you are but you're selling in my
territory so now i'm going to kill you
and take your drug because you shouldn't
be selling over here that happens too
there's all kinds of problems with dope
and when you're getting especially when
you get a dope for sales
and
it used to be
gangs all bottles were territorial
and then when they started becoming
mobile was with dope
and they started crossing the lines and
then you started getting people killing
people because they were selling in my
area
emmett came in and said we're going to
start taxing you people on the sales of
dope
you know it just became a lot of very
very problematic so whenever we had
a drug related
murder
we link it to drugs then i rely on the
drug experts to tell me okay give me all
your intelligence let's find out who's
who's who in the zoo who are we dealing
with what's going on where does this
come from and they've got a pretty good
idea
you work it backwards
because uh
i think even when like you know i was
around you you were around like at the
disco club the district era
and you know even athletes got into it
sure a couple of dodgers uh you had it
best you how i remember when
their
i mean a
favor was called in
by mr o'malley
two
then
uh sherman block i wanna say sharon blog
was after pitches sherm block and it was
during the steve howe era and who the
contacts were and where it was coming
from and they made them all they they
were able to find out where it was
coming from
they had it bad on steho
and whoever was but you know some guys
uh
strawberry
and goodin you know that met documentary
the thirty percent straw barrier
strawberry
daryl really went uh down the tubes it's
too bad he was a great player
he was a great player there's a great um
adam mckay did a whole podcast called
death at the wing that was about like in
particular cocaine deaths of basketball
players in the 80s and it sort of got
into some of the wider stuff too
um but just really fascinating how much
that sort of bias infiltrated yeah lynn
bias being the big one because he was
what like first or second pick in the
draft or something like that
just died
that would have changed the celtics a
lot that was at a time but he would have
played against magic and he would play
against jordan yeah we've been playing
with bird
bird he want to win a couple
championships i think one of the big
what ifs like
less than two days after he was
he was uh chosen
for the draft he was gone yeah i think
he was like selling like when he was
partying celebrating getting drafted
that's awful man that's crazy right
you ready for an out of the world
experience guys look at look no further
than the performance package 4.0 from
manscape and it really does make a
difference i'm going to say it really
does make a difference guys i mean
this isn't the 70s is it no no if you
look at some old
videos of adult videos there's a lot of
stuff going on down there
and
now
there's hardly any palitos but
it's
you know like the cars are faster like
formula one
now back then as opposed to now
manscaped has brought in formula one
what's your one
to a new level a new speed there you go
i said and inside this package you'll
find a lot their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your whole solar system you
know what there's there's nothing better
i think in the world of uh
of webbles
than ball deodorant because
i think every dude has given himself the
the sidewall the check and i have a
sidewall test and you're like all right
you know it's a little bit
a little bit of like you know
there's some things that gold bond
leaves to manscape like gold bond is
beautiful
but
what they're doing over here
at manscape is they're preparing you for
a future
of uh
less odor and less irritation
who wouldn't want that who would who
would want more odor
it's like buttering up your turkey put
ball butter down there
[Laughter]
there's some of the stuff that's uh
that's really good i mean i think at the
end of the day
we're our own best advocates
absolutely kenogil that's it
and the weed whacker is also waterproof
and it uses a 9 000
rpm
motor listen your pedals don't have a
chance and
a 360 degree rotary dual blade system no
cutting
like myself at the four seasons in
houston no cutting
and a nose and hair trimmer
but also you know guys don't forget
about those
brush and that [ __ ] eyebrows that i
got but all of that stuff works in
conjunction like you know
there's
you know women live for a couple of
things but one of the things they
most like to do is
pull and pull hair from your ears
and your nose but they leave your you
know well it's kind of
you know alone it's on you that's on us
like it's all landscape it's like a
turkey neck
the lawnmower 40 also has a 4000 led
spotlight you can turn on and off when
needed for a more precise
shave throughout your travels across the
universe
and uh if i wanted uh maybe a discount
and free shipping what uh is there code
i can use you can get 20 off and free
shipping
with the code delegate
omg hi
at manscape.com
for a clean trinity and beyond
your spaceballs will thank you
i remember that movie spaceballs yeah
this is better because that one was a
long time ago yeah and pillows have
changed
they have
changing the universe
climate change ball change bellow chains
that's it cholos shave
their heads
real men shave
their penis that's right
even like a dui i'm sure some officers
used to look the other way but
not anymore right in the old days i i've
taken home more drunks than i ever
arrested
and in the old days
you'd get keys and throw them in the
trunk of the car and
go go down the windchills and
we'll drop you off get some coffee drink
some coffee by the time you figure out
how to get your keys out call somebody
you know you're okay
and what about when the car is mad you
couldn't get in the [ __ ] garage into
the into the trunk if you didn't have
your key yeah like now you hit a button
the back thing opens yeah how do you get
back in there
you'd have to take the seat out the back
seat up but you could you could get in
but
now you can get in opens up by itself
the gas station opens if you're like a
tesla you can be like hey hey tesla open
up my my trunk yeah yeah
so you know today you have
mothers i'm not against any of these
mothers against drunk drivers
so they follow everything if you don't
push for you know
okay in the old days before there was
mothers against drunk drivers
if i took a drunk driver and dropped him
off at his house or i took his keys put
him in the trunk of the car and got him
some coffee it saved me time on the
streets
to be able to get really apprehend bad
guys yeah not just a drunk driver
whereas mothers against drunk drivers
would be saying you're not helping the
rest of us out he needs to go through
the system he should have been doing
this you should have been doing that so
i was remiss
or derelict in my duties by not
taking full action but there's nothing
that says mandated me it wasn't a
mandatory arrest yeah you know so those
are powers of discretion are we live i
think i'm going live all right so what
would you tell me we'll talk with you
right here um
yeah the the um
but you couldn't do that in it you
couldn't no and body cameras too i mean
maybe they don't show
well do body cameras lie no body cameras
body camera on the back the last [ __ ]
going on behind them
you know i don't see that [ __ ] body
cameras are good but here's what happens
okay so you you take the guy you drop
him off at windshields he's drunk by the
time he figures it out he gets back to
his car but he gets his ass kicked right
there winchell's
then it's your fault because you didn't
protect the guy you made it man that
couldn't take care of himself
you made him a a victim
so people started getting sued people
started doing this so now with all the
civil liabilities again all you do is
what you got to do by the letter of the
law yeah
also you just you just cover the law by
the letter of the law and better will a
police officer still do a solid for
somebody or that that kind of goes away
with
with um
whatever it is whatever they're asking
you to do you gotta you gotta take under
consideration
is it really worth me losing my job
who's going to pay for my bills who's
going to take care of my family is it
really worth it for for me to help out
this guy for me to lose my job
and that's where we are now before where
before a police officer might have said
hey
you know
um amen listen you've had a little bit
too much to drink
so i'm sorry officer you know i thought
i was trying to make it home or whatever
and he's like okay come with respect
appreciate it you know work a lot of
hours got with these guys had a couple
drinks you know i don't mean any harm
yeah you know i mean i don't want to go
to jail i'll pull over i'll walk home or
whatever and you know you could do that
and now maybe you
now maybe you can't yeah it's a little
took away it took away that i can
remember taking a guy out of a bar in
commerce we got a call disturbing the
peace inside a drunk inside didn't want
to leave they didn't serve him i go in
there and as i'm walking in he says i
know you are we went to school together
now it's your cop you're going to kick
my ass like you did in high school
and i didn't remember the guy initially
and so i said no not at all
we're we're in the city of commerce and
this guy still lived in in opico
picobiago
and i said tell you what brother come on
let me give you a ride home
and you know you've got brothers back
there let your brother come back and
pick up your truck a big commercial
diesel truck
he just went in there and got blasted he
couldn't drive couldn't do this couldn't
do that
and so i just got on the radio and told
my desk i'm going to be off the air for
15 minutes put him in the back seat of
my car with my partner and then we just
hauled ask the pico got him dumped him
off
said there you go saved him a bunch of
money saved everybody a bunch of trouble
and now we're back back on duty where if
we would have done it
taken him to jail impounded his vehicle
it would have cost him thousands of
dollars by the time he was done it would
have taken me out of the field for at
least an hour
we're now in 15 minutes i'm back ready
to rock and roll and everybody's happy
okay so what about everybody going out
and getting over served which i think is
now because of the you know some people
can go out
you know and then you see them
they're a little bit over served when
you see all the videos of people being
overseer if you're in a if you're in a
party
which i think mostly you can see it's
going to go bad right sure somebody gets
if you have two people over served what
can what should the friends do
or people do
um should they
let's say we're in a party
someone's acting a little bit crazy
getting a little bit loud
what should
let's say i'm in that party and i'm not
i know that guy maybe potentially might
be an issue
do i try to talk to him myself or do i
go around and maybe talk to the manager
and say hey
you know we're going to try to get this
trying to get my manager here manager
better be protected himself and i've
seen now
not that i attend bars on a regular
basis but i've been into a few bars
and i've seen bartenders bar owners now
yeah instruct their bartenders hey that
guy's had too much cut him off no more
yeah and they are being very cognizant
of it
parties at a house you gotta be
i gotta be cognizant but you know i have
a grandson
recently turned 22 he had his buddies
down the house
and they all had a great time they had
beer i did i didn't care
i just told them
nobody's gonna get drunk here and then
think they're going to drive home
i got plenty of floor space yeah
this is this is going to be it i'll
drive i'll do this so they decided they
stopped drinking they had been swimming
they're going to go to another house and
continue the party over there
and i got my two grandkids a 27 22 year
old
said hey you're gonna go over there she
says yeah papa i stopped drinking long
time i said no no no no no
i'll pay for the uber got uber down here
drive him down there i'll pay for it i
don't care you're not gonna be driving
tonight just makes and and i think this
uber has really made things better for
drunks
yes it's a lot easier it's a lot cheaper
to pay 40 for an uber yeah than it is to
go ahead and pay four thousand dollars
for an attorney and bail in a fine yeah
and you know um
there's people that
i mean
though you know the beautiful thing
about having you in here is you can
really ask
the questions that i want the answers to
can you drive
at what point is someone impaired like
i'm not i'm not i've never been i mean
you know i'm a notorious i think drinker
yeah you can just you know
a little bit you got your face on the
can
yeah i do but i'm a little bit you know
i made a lot of mistakes drinking
um
at what point
is someone impaired like it's not .08 i
mean come on you know i probably woke up
this morning important oh [ __ ] 90.
the law says 0.08 whether you are or not
that's what the law says 0.8 is almost
nothing exactly
i i understand that but
if you get an announcement as a question
off top topic
if you go to church hungover
and you go drink
some of the wine does it look down that
guy would look at you and say hey come
on don't try to
don't try to kill your hangover by
coming and get communion and take it
because it's blood at that point so
i i don't think so i think what i mean
hey you're good i would be like i'm
gonna go and get some bread yeah for my
stomach it's a little bit i need a base
layer down there yeah
just a wafer but
0.08
is the law it's it's is that lower is
that adequate i that's science that's
they say
it is so if you get involved in a here's
the bottom line
if you're just driving at a .08 you're
probably right on the border like you
probably pass a field sobriety test i
shouldn't say that but you probably
could it's right there but if you got an
accident and say you were injured in
that actually they took you to the
hospital they drew blood and it's going
to show 0.08 you're drunk
yeah you know bottom line they've
they've made a they've made a limit
there it is
and if it's beyond that you're impaired
and that's we we can't change that
that's the law somebody said that's load
uh oh my man jesse
that's a low percentage she's saying
it's a low 0.08 yeah yeah yeah but also
you're blacked out at
0.15
i mean who knows
i went to the car right down the street
from the east l.a station once i was
bagging patrol
and i knew i was going to get blasted we
had a bed going on and i so i knew i was
gonna get blessed i said okay i'm gonna
do this
but i want you to drive me back to the
station you somebody drive my car drive
back the station then just let me sleep
there at the station
i'm gonna try and drive when i got to
the station i said okay put me on the
breathalyzer i want to see because i
knew i bought how am i doing here yeah
and it wasn't that high
how many drinks did you have oh [ __ ] i
remember
i was toasted trust me but beard driving
is different
than
margarita driving
and vodka driving unfortunately blood
alcohol doesn't say whether you're
drinking whiskey wine beer
well blood alcohol doesn't say but
you know like if you're drinking if you
and i are drinking wild turkey and we're
[ __ ] kissing at the end and we're
like hey put on [ __ ] kiss man and
then you're like hey i'm all right to
drive and you start the car twice which
i've you know when you started the car
twice
and that's again that's as good as
anything
and i feel like i get higher on on wine
i i get and why too i feel like i get
buzzed on on wine
more than i do
alcohol or or beer but do anybody
believe there's anybody's here does
anybody thought chingnaso's drinking
wine like
you know hey jim you've had a little too
much chardonnay get your hands off me
you pinwhop you don't know i'm drinking
[ __ ] i don't think people have
told you drinking wine like hey
hold your [ __ ] zinfandel i don't
think anybody's ever said hold your
sympathy
by the way don't invite [ __ ] grand
i'm about to can't hold this pinot noir
i can't hold my sand dude
and all those are [ __ ] why i just drink
cabernet or myrtle red wine yeah you
like dream wine huh yeah i do
and and it's it's good for me it's good
for my heart
it's it's got it all this [ __ ]
said
0.08 is the pre-party level yeah
that's your sunday afternoon yeah you
got to hit point by the free game but um
do people drink
all like yesterday morning on the way to
the golf tournament cedric's tournament
which was amazing
i was trying to find a place to get a
bloody mary at nine o'clock in l.a which
is you can't get one in the [ __ ]
house
to your point i think golf courses are
sort of like the one of the few places
where it's like when it's open a lot of
them can serve
oh man that's that's i mean if you can't
get a margarita you can't get a bloody
berry
with some olives in there like those are
like little little like little taquitos
you know like olive
you know they even sell big they make
all of that you could put some [ __ ]
garden a salad inside one yeah
at that point just give me the carnage
why am i messing around
but
yeah yeah alcohol can can enhance a good
time it can [ __ ] destroy
uh good times i think
some bands that uh
that i've known of that
had uh great accomplishments but by the
end of the night they had
turned into you know fights and stuff
because because nobody knows when to
you know they say when to say when but
nobody knows when to stop like we're all
in love and then another hour somebody's
pushing somebody you're like hey the
glass breaks once the glass breaks
that's that this really pull the plug
never i've never uh
the way you see me now
is the same way i am when i'm if i've
been drinking extensively in high school
you were like that like what i see
always always laughing carrying on i
don't change i've never been in a fight
when i'm drunk i don't get pissed off
when i'm drunk
uh if i think
i'll tell a story on myself let's take
some questions from the people but go
ahead and see if everybody no no go
ahead but tell the story on yourself we
went uh we went on a cruise
and i'm with the wife and some other
couples and you know they have those
formal dinners
well i remember we were out there
drinking i was drinking these some kind
of drink in a special glass they were
souvenir glasses
so i wanted to take a bunch of souvenir
glasses back with me you know they were
so i'm paying for all the [ __ ] and i got
ripped
and now it's time for the formal dinner
and my wife's instead of the [ __ ]
souvenir glasses
he's rich
over there
at the
california adventure i had some
[ __ ] finding nemo [ __ ] margaritas
that was all about also
38 hours i was bothered
but i had an arm full of i'm taking them
home with me i'm all happy the wife says
you know what it's time for the dinner
why don't you just stay here
and i'll go to dinner with her with our
friends you just stay here and go to
sleep
and i say yeah but i want to just kill
please you've had too much to drink just
stay here i said all right
so she leaves do you remember that or
not oh yes yes i remember i don't
remember a lot of this because i was i i
thought i'd be a traviso i was wearing
white shorts i had a red shirt you know
the the
coca-cola yeah yeah well i'm wearing a
muscle shirt that says gomekaka
at the formal dinner that means eat [ __ ]
and i walk i walk into the formal dinner
and my commodity just says
looking at my wife says commander don't
look now but he's back
and
everybody's in tuxedos and former wear
and i walk in wearing a gomez
the wife says
gil and all i can do is i just hung my
head and i said
i know i know bad decision i know i know
and she walked me back to the room never
got angry never got upset i just i know
it was gonna take man if you're married
i think you've been married 52 years 50
years 50 years and it's and if she
doesn't get mad he found the right it's
a it's a good thing oh yeah
yeah
did she ever get mad at it yeah she's
been mad at me a few times but you have
to understand i mean when he talks about
other ladies on the podcast
i didn't hear about that one no she did
she didn't she didn't that's not what
she got she was
trust me she was mad at me before
eight months she was mad at me
for what
oh no no we're not doing this we're not
going to talk about that discretion we
can slide right by that but what does
that happen
what did i miss was iran at that time no
no you were a comedian but i mean yeah
yeah but this was long and i was
referencing like the first kiss i think
conversation but you know what wow oh
[ __ ] oh wait a minute but but uh
listen matt i don't know how dudes think
that they can talk about other women
or girls think they can talk about other
guys
and that
the person that you're with is not going
to [ __ ] be upset like can you i don't
know
does it matter
yes within reason like i get for for me
at least something like okay if you're
telling us you have to be really secure
too yeah which is the hardest part i
think most people i screwed up recently
that on here on your show listen man you
don't have to say it like don't don't
feel like you need to no no no no i
screwed up here on your show when i
talked about seeing that old that old
girl where i said something
and
and she got pissed off of me that's the
only time kill she never just parted all
out
but go ahead and touch again yeah let me
know she wasn't you know she was upset
that i had really said something
and i didn't think anything of it but it
didn't it didn't last an angry match he
was just pissing me and i said it i'd
seen a girl that i had kissed in third
grade
the first girl that every kid is and i
said hey here was that i mean i still
remember that kiss and my wife got
pissed off
i mean i was in third grade great yeah
you guys had to be the 1950
[ __ ] you know what year was that
nice okay been married for faithful okay
so probably about 1957
that's when it happened spilling the
beans somebody said spill the beans and
i hadn't i have not agreed
there's been nothing since but the fact
that i brought it up in front of her
she she was not happy so
there's no statute of limitations no
there is first kiss i don't know
in terms of like getting some mileage
out of the story like you should be able
to tell that whenever is that what
you're saying i'm saying that you should
be able to tell the story you know ad
nauseum i don't even know what that
means that that would work
i
because it's been so long yeah that
you're like
okay i didn't know you you were
i mean you guys aren't the same age
right she was younger no you guys are
the same age so she's a little older
she's a little older tonight
so are you supposed to say that
at the home office here so
so
the difference between us and you talk
about being secure if i was your partner
i take the keys right now throw them in
the [ __ ] trunk
[Laughter]
right now i'll take your bus hey let's
go to the windshield and just get you
some coffee
you talk about
being secure
now see my wife
when we broke up you know when i was a
kid went in the army and then she i was
gone and she'd go back with her
ex-boyfriend went back and forth
okay well
he actually
asked her to marry him which she
didn't accept yeah yeah yeah but they
were an item
so
let us say within the last 10 years he
passed away
and my wife still keeps in touch with
her cousins their commanders and the
guys still in the world
he passed away and she was telling me
how she felt bad that he passed away and
i told her hey
you want to go to the funeral go to the
funeral it's not going to upset me
because you know yeah go it doesn't
matter but just remember
you dumped him for me
maybe his family ain't gonna be too
happy to see you there that's true
so there's something you got to think
about
you know i i don't if
you want to go go that's very true yeah
but it did it doesn't bother me grant
you want to operate this and see yeah
you can answer some questions if the
people it's live we're live all right
but you're allowed to put it on us the
whole time uh let's go have another beer
there you go
got more but
years ago
when i was at the
ice house i said to
uh when i was married i said i ran into
my old girlfriend at the ice house
and that became an issue but she just
happened to be there and i ran into her
like you know i would i didn't invite
her
but
you know that one you know that didn't
wasn't received very well old girlfriend
i was married do you end up interacting
did you just like make a comment okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
you don't like the way you you're
putting me on that's not right
no no no but yeah i i
no nothing was received very well yeah
so let's just kind of stay away from
that i've never been i never i've never
uh
unfortunately
what is it like to have a partner that's
understanding
for the most part
you know i i got to believe
there's got to be some trust there
you know what there's got to be trust i
mean
what are they what where the
insecurities come from do the
insecurities
insecurities don't come from when you
just meet that person your
[ __ ] childhood your own observations
when i met her i was playing in the band
and even ugly guys get their underwear
uh women's underwear thrown at them you
know they all want to be groupies and so
that's how i met my wife what is it
about music that makes women and even
dudes like get their palettes hard like
hey
you know i've been to some concerts
where fruit oh yeah i'm not just oh
and the way to become a good musician
is not attractive at all you know
sit in your room and practice [ __ ]
garage you're in your room somewhere and
practicing over and over and over again
you know so here it is i meet her we get
married the midnighters yes now late 70s
i'm working gangs at east l.a and i have
to sit on a surveillance on a gang
murder one night
and i catch up with her and the rest of
my buddies from the band they're having
a little mini reunion at a house
and the lead singer on the band is
sitting there saying gil
so uh you know we just lost our sax
player we're doing nightclubs right now
why don't you go why don't you play with
us were you married at that time yes
with my wife forever though no you
remember you got 20 you were 21. yeah i
was only one when i got married that's
already up there you're already a
[ __ ] spinster at that age
so you know i got some great it's
sounding good to me you know start
playing and the first thing the wife
said was oh no [ __ ] you're not going
out there and doing that again because
she remembered
what it was like yeah when i was playing
what was it like it was it was fun it
was fun like i said even ugly fat guys a
lot of undies getting tossed on stage
so she didn't want me to do that now
years later
the band's getting together
and they're gonna do a reunion
and she's saying
go ahead
you know it's like you're old you know
yeah
it's it's
how many years have gone by
uh [ __ ] since i was
uh back then i was probably about 25
when
uh they hit me up to go start playing
with them again
and now i'm in my 50s
you know early 60s okay so she said all
right go ahead so she thinks the step
you know she thinks yeah that doesn't
there's no way that this music
he's affect women at
50 the way it did whenever and you were
in choice not only that she i'm sure she
threw in there i'm a little more mature
i have responsibilities you know i have
i have family of kids i have a house and
you're not gonna throw it all the way
just to have fun and and she's gonna be
going out when i play she's gonna go out
with me all the time anyway but does it
sound like ultimately she trusted you
more or just did the math and was like
well he's got too much to lose it's
probably not going to happen i i think
it was a combination she trusted me more
the math
and what can you really do old man
who are you going to attract
she had confidence in those old dudes
that still control paulo not me but i
mean there's some
i hope to shout
huh i don't know
i hope to shout brother
i'm 71. so
how was it so
what was it like do you still love the
music i still love the music and then
we're all all older
oh yeah there were and there were there
were people there but i mean i had my
wife now when i go out and play i do
these reunion things i got my wife i got
my kids out there
i mean we played my we played at my 70th
birthday party put the band together at
steven's steakhouse we got up there and
playing yeah and gilly and then you love
steven's this is this place is a great
idea we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
go to stephen's stay home and do the
anniversary show oh yeah it's stephen
steakhouse during the day so we can get
all bubbles today right there then let
me loose on the five minutes there you
go [ __ ] go to alpine village
alpine building you ever been alpine
village i've been buying never been to
it
i just passed it i thought it wasn't
even around anymore no it's off the off
the harbor off the harbor freeway yeah
we're gonna have the
we should probably call alpine village
we should probably have the anniversary
show at alpine five and stevens it's a
whole yeah
when's the anniversary show
that's actually good
tomorrow yeah yeah what's it the
anniversary of you know
what there's all things going on it have
to be
right so there's a lot of people on on
instagram live
um here's a question just open-ended
like all right would you would would
anybody who was married in a band or
married in a profession
would you still be as excited
to do your job if you had to take your
spouse with you a hundred percent of the
time most definitely
i really would i'm gonna say [ __ ] no
way i would say yeah i i i don't care
because i don't have my tongue pulled
out of my cool
take
and with me to
that's true also much easier to pull
that off if you don't have the wi-fi
don't complain about the santa barculo
back there on at my
uh liquor store job on pure blossom
highway whatever [ __ ] i see it i'm not
worried
anymore about my wife going with me
because i'm not doing anything i i love
playing
i love playing i love playing for my
wife you know if she's there listening
and she likes it i love it
uh i went around and then i it just easy
i got none to hide nothing there
she loves me we still dance matter of
fact somebody posted something i didn't
i saw that i said oh wait you posted i
saw something very sweet on your
instagram oh man what was that that was
uh but you know you're one of those
those few others that's like married 50
years and still loves you guys are still
in love great partners you have fun
together you go out as a family that's
it's very anti-fucking
very latino you never seen a chicano go
hey kids come on let's go to this party
that they're having in my honor be like
about my [ __ ] kids there yeah no it
was uh it's great it was fun and it was
it was a little tough a little misty
because i haven't danced with her in a
while because of this getting dizzy and
[ __ ]
uh so i just they were playing sabor me
and it's a beautiful song and so i told
her i said hey you want that [ __ ] are
you serious i said yes this is beautiful
i'm gonna say and so we gotta
and have
and we both
had tears in her eyes
the first time we danced in a while
and the fact that i was dancing it was a
beautiful song nice
uh she was afraid you know it was pretty
good comments here too everybody needs a
healthy space i like that i i like that
idea of it but
for for you
it was very you know
i'm gonna say i'm not sure that the way
that i was raised i was gonna be a good
partner for life you know unfortunately
like those things are those things are
etched kind of in a young person yeah
but to see you and your wife dancing i
reposted that thing because i thought it
was beautiful
i mean i admire you i mean i really do i
admire you guys i've been around you
guys you know and seeing the documentary
i saw you and then i saw i saw uh her
and then i thought well i'm gonna meet
her but i felt like i already kind of
knew her and that's what she said when
she came up to me like
by the way she said to tell you you know
it's like you're familiar when i was
leaving she says hey don't forget tell
jordan i said hi yeah i think she's a
beautiful person man i mean just
in seeing her and seeing her on the
documentary which i watched like you
know almost like if i like something i
watch it like five times in a row
because i
you know you know i'm i'm mr crime but i
inherit that stuff in me like you know i
i see that stuff i'm not sure where i
might have been a lot smarter i don't
know when documentaries started but
in my in the 70s you couldn't see a
[ __ ] documentary anywhere national
geographic yes i mean certainly not like
in today where you can go that should be
i just used to watch it for the women
for the natives
for the hotties
yeah but then what do they have uh
mutual of omaha wild kingdom yeah oh wow
yeah but you couldn't see a an actual
documentary on on something
no no
no no they're everywhere even like
podcasts too i just saw my daughter just
sent me some some other thing
uh netflix just put it out
top 10
uh shows
on netflix for the first six months of
the year oh yeah and we were number five
oh hell yeah right in the middle so
that's uh
that's pretty good not not anymore grand
look up though
they're probably what else could they be
well it's hot over there
yeah
bridgeton played a lot longer than mine
did and they were just right before me
either right in front of me or right
after me
but but
do you ever get over
i don't know man
not for you but let's say for the people
watching
on instagram do you get do you ever get
over like your first love like the maybe
someone that you didn't end up with yeah
the girl that i kissed in the third
grade
[ __ ] dog
i'm just left no he's saying he got over
that he's saying
my
my daughter one time my middle daughter
she was asking me and she had to be
about
10 years old 12 years old she says dad
how long do how old do i have to be
before i start dating
and i said get out of here she said no
really dad how old are you do i have to
be before i start dating i said okay 35
or when you get out of the convent
whichever comes first
and then she says dad dude she said i
bet you mom was the first girl you ever
kissed you were a nerd and she started
laughing
and were you a nerd you weren't no no
no
but didn't didn't being a chicano help
you as a police officer though yeah
almost definitely like those guys felt
exactly but that wasn't it that wasn't a
uh
it wasn't a skill you had when those
guys said hey carrillo's like
he's a good dude
you when when they said you were feeding
it
that wasn't an act you no you just
happened to be a chicano that ended up
being a police officer that's right for
the detective that's right
yeah
like some of those others try to be like
i don't think you can be
pretend to be cool i mean maybe but
those guys would pick it up like the
[ __ ] street dudes they're smarter
they are
there was a guy that grew up on the same
block i did and he became a he became a
cop about three months before i did
and as soon as he found out that i'd
pass everything i was going in he came
up to me said okay first thing you got
to do is forget everybody here on the
block forget everything about the
neighborhood
and because it's a different world now
and i went in and i kept telling myself
you can't forget all everything that
you've done everywhere you've been
so
i became one graduated my work topped
out
i'd go back on the block
and i'd have a beer with the guys there
was nothing and then they finally copped
out they said you know what you come
around here
we love you brother you were part of us
you're still one of us you'll always be
part of us he said the other guy
see he comes around here we'll [ __ ] him
up
we don't like him he thinks he's too
good he's a piece of [ __ ]
you know he just
and he was darker than i was but they
didn't like him
and they could just tell that the dude
wasn't a good dude sure
which i think you know they know but
street cred goes it goes a long way i
mean i don't know now you know um
but you know because everybody kind of
moves into different
different um
neighborhoods but when you got street in
you you have street in you the whole
time sure when i bought when i bought
the house that i live in now the
neighbor was bitching because you know
the trees were in my
in my on my side of the property and the
guys that live there it's [ __ ]
expensive to cut trees like trim trees
yeah that's why nobody ever trims them i
don't know how the [ __ ] that
it got to be
a thousand dollars to have somebody come
and trim palm trees which if you look
around
none of them are done or in homes even
so this guy so this guy's telling me you
know 17 years these guys lived in the
house that i bought
they never trimmed the trees it got all
congested and then the pollen and it
would blew that [ __ ] blew into your
house oh it does so i said i'm going to
trim these trees and the guy's like i
think we should trim these trees like 30
i'm not you know [ __ ] that man we'll
trim like [ __ ] 60 let's see they look
bare and the neighbor you know lived in
canada and he lived here and he comes
back and
he he's you know the office calls
they're like hey your neighbor's upset
i said about what about the trees
and i said what about them
that you trimmed them and you didn't let
them know i said they're on my [ __ ]
yard my trail i'm gonna let this guy
know yeah that i'm gonna trim the trees
that are in my yard yeah and he goes he
wants to come over and talk to you i
said i said tell that dude
not to come over do not do that they're
cut already what am i going to do
glue them back on this [ __ ] dude
comes over and he says
and you know
whenever everybody has a trigger you
know what do you say when you're pissed
off and you notice about the shit's
about to go down i say can i help you
that's what
that's what i say
when chingazos are about to go down
can i help you this guy's like yeah i'm
a little disappointed in you and what
that you trim the trees without
you know asking me
and i said well why would i ask you
well you know my privacy
you know i said what [ __ ] your privacy
like i said you know my treat
not a tree and he's like well you know
you didn't those guys came into my yard
which they didn't
and then i said no they didn't they you
know how they do now they grab it with a
rope and they sure so they don't ruin
the yard and this guy was convinced that
they had gone into his yard i'm like man
they didn't
he's like well i think they did
like man i'm not going to debate you
know these trees with you they're in my
yard yeah you can get an attorney you
can do it that way but i'm not going to
stand here and talk to you about some
[ __ ] that's already done and he says oh
is that right and i said
yeah that's right and i don't you
haven't thought ginazo says back in like
ninth grade
and i said just you know if i were you
i'd probably go home
you know
might be easier for me
and then um now you guys are best
friends put up some bikers [ __ ] him
yeah and he put up some ficus i guess to
block you out i pulled a pull a gun on
him
in my balcony nobody saw it just me
she's like talking about 10 all crazy
babies
in the afternoon
but awful i mean neighbor disputes are
they're they're big they become they're
really deadly oh yeah what does it say
tall fences make good neighbors like
this
you know the one thing about instagram
there's a lot of things bad about it but
i love the people that follow you now
you know i told them to follow you but
they really man
i think they would be people that have
you said hey i need ten dudes
at seven o'clock to meet me in griffith
park i think they'd be 25. oh yeah
oh yeah i think there would be there
there's some ex-military i bet you look
right now they're going yes that's me
i'm there just just give me the address
or jason
yeah
so as as um
here's something i've never told anybody
all right at my age because already
we're about those asking
and seeing your video
you know i'm 60 right
and i don't think that
that i want to end up
uh alone
like my therapist
told me i would be 10 years old
he was correct
but i think i i think i want to try to
you know find somebody to be with
hopefully he's a tender gentleman
i'm fluent find your own dating game
kind of flew it up but i'm this fluid
right i don't know what fluid is
i'm this fluid
that's but i don't want to i don't
aaron you have somebody right yeah yeah
[ __ ] it too late
so
no but i think i
and seeing that video and seeing things
in life it's going by fast man i don't
think i want to be i don't think i want
to be alone the rest of my life
or just with my golf clubs i mean
now
y'all know that's a little bit sad it
gets a little sad on any of the apps i
think we talked a little bit about raya
the other day right
uh
or orto right maybe we're on
you know
there's some potatoes out there i mean
i don't mean like young i mean but he
does in their 50s
good ladies
there's good ladies in their 50s huh
yeah oh yeah little ladies i think
they're all torn up by life
like if you go hey let's go listen to
some jazz they're like oh i'm not gonna
i know what that means like they're so
beat down by life that listen to jazz do
you want to go listen to jazz it's your
euphemism not your life
like they think it all means something
else
like rusty trombone
[Laughter]
see you later thank you for listening
thank you they follow you
at real guild career
oh yeah and uh we're bringing bobby lee
back oh yeah we'll get him back on the
podcast
he's on the tiger belly thank you
everybody for uh hanging out with us and
we'll see you again we'll do it again
here do you know how to end it did you i
didn't save it i don't know
how to that was fun though hey how do i
end it and save it
how does the ending say that people on
instagram how do we answer i still don't
know how to answer it
what phone do you have use your ipad on
phone i use my iphone and my have you
done more clubhouse
uh no no what else do we do did we like
clubhouse what else did we like
because clubhouse oh the other one was
uh do we share it to igtv is that what
you wanted all right
what was the one um
what would you talk about twitch
you know i've gone on twitch
but i still don't really don't
understand that one you know i see a
bunch of stuff on there i just i've gone
what do we tell austin we're going to do
on twitch
we're going to have a no we're gonna
have a uh
banned uh
a
contest oh your talent show is that's a
challenge show yeah
yeah
there we go it's posting right now that
was the the instagram q a within a show
well miles pallavas man we're getting
we're close to uh signing some people
that's the uh the music label right yeah
awesome can we be here for that episode
or the no okay
so you just launched
because he was in a band yeah you're a
sax guy is that what i heard yes yeah
i'ma cut him in on my uh we have a label
me and the singer andy vargas from
santana
and we're in the process of signing a
couple of uh
of young artists man
i've got the guys looking for i just got
a call from my bass guitar player a
couple of weeks ago and he's looking now
evidently they have a dvd
that i didn't get a copy of they have
they have a copy and on dvd
of me blowing that uh
well harlem nocturne
that song yeah where at a
fire department would have closed down
we were at a big uh nightclub
and it was a grand opening or they have
a big deal so they had
three bands
that they used to play together back in
the 60s
and
we did it and you it was
packed
and you could hear him screaming you
could hear him uh
it was loud it was good
and it's that
harlem nectar and saxophone solo that i
used to play
you know what uh killer
you couldn't play the national anthem on
your saks could you well you can play
anything on it you know but i i never
did play it yeah the um
september 11th i think we're taking a
field trip we're going to go to staples
and we're going to see a de la hoya
fight
oh yeah you want to go yeah yes
well now probably not not not to the you
know pro used to go with me because i
told her i used to be a ring announcer
but before that oh yeah i'd go to the
fights i'd go to the olympic auditorium
almost every week so i'm [ __ ] number
two and she was she was sitting there
saying you know hey well how come i
never get to go with you you know
because you know i've seen women down
there and i said it's a different yeah
you don't understand here
so i i just told her i said okay you can
go with us i said but chivalry is good
i love that [ __ ] i see women down there
yeah because it is it's a bit of a yeah
chivalry's dead there would be like a a
row of five soucious you know they'd get
up they were all blind bombshell they'd
get up everybody would whistle they
cheered you know just
they're like strippers they'd get up and
they'd go up there and come down
so she wanted to go so i said okay
shiver is dead that night don't ask me
to protect you
this is a fight it's a real thing it's
impossible so we got down there and the
one thing about the olympics if the
fights are no good on the inside some
drunk would get fighting behind you
right so here comes the fights and the
guy falls down in front of me and she's
come on let's go let's get and i said no
no no you said you want to be here let's
go you know all i did was push him back
up go ahead finish your chin gossip
some guy got i'll never forget it
from the balcony
got a beer and threw it down on an lapd
cop
right on him and the guy just looked up
and he said oh why did you waste that
beer
but didn't go up charging after him
didn't do anything let it go when it's
when you say up it's really not it
wasn't that big far up no because it was
very intimate uh it was a great they
still it's still out there yeah but it's
it's a church now they sold to a uh
church if anybody's if anybody's out
there it's funny because i was just
talking about this if anybody's out
there that's
that
is in la that has access to what would
have been the olympic games
i would love to go in there
and be able to take a tour of it right
yeah if it's if it resembles like with
the locker rooms i've been in the locker
rooms because i did ring announcing
there and and it was
it was awesome how big a place was it
because to me small the locker room was
there only a thousand
oh yeah
you could fit
i'm sure a few couple of thousand
and about five thousand maybe four
thousand small small on the inside and
then the arena because they used it i
believe as an olympic
venue
for uh back in the day they did yeah is
this the one is this the one downtown
yes grand avenue
i would almost listen i don't know what
shape it's in but
i would almost do my last special at the
olympic auditorium yeah
it was special so i don't know if those
seats are still there or whatever but we
took her down and as we were leaving the
arena that night
the lapd were lined up waiting for this
guy threw the beer oh [ __ ] and he came
out and the cop just went up to say
remember me and they
beat his ass wow as he's so just they
knew who that dude was they knew who he
was
they waited for it and they beat us and
he just came out like hey took him to
jail he was drunk
and they they did what they had to do
you know but that place like
you know almost like the old the old
arenas in in in towns like you know
boston cars not around anymore
but
from the olympic when you stepped
outside you were on a sidewalk you
weren't on
uh
in an area where you could walk to your
car yeah you came out of the olympia all
those doors said like four doors on each
side and when you when they opened the
door
you were on a sidewalk you were in the
street that's it
i mean [ __ ] no frills great
architecture on the
outside and then the box office tickets
those little the little sconces on the
outside were like you know just all the
way around it i went to a fight uh loma
lee
versus reuben navarro
reuben nevada from east lake yeah yeah
yeah and the fans were chanting rue ben
rue bit and over on this side all the
mexicans were saying lo mali lo mali and
i was with my dad my dad was there and
all of a sudden the fight broke out up
in the stand beers were fly and i
watched my dad grab the rail and jump
over the rail
to get out you know
it scared the [ __ ] out of everybody and
i thought oh this is
this is not good but we got out and they
broke up the fight eventually we got on
time but it was how did you become a
ring announcer that's that's i started
that with the department they asked me
to do it at the local fights you know
hey kill you'll get up there with you
and just fights between deputies you
judge matches they used to be able to do
they should be able to do that right
yeah these people have
fights between deputies yeah they had
grudge magic to get up there and they
did it and he'd have his ring guys and
then the other guy would have his guys
they were [ __ ] detective there were
deputies going at it deputies and then
it grew from that
i enjoyed it and i guess i did it
decently
to the when they had
interdepartmental lapd versus the
sheriff's department and i started doing
those then it became the police olympics
[ __ ] and started doing the police
olympics and then
i got a couple of pro flights you know
but to do it in the pros
you know they've got their people the
california athletic you know the boxing
commission they know who they're gonna
yeah so unless you get into them
uh
you think that would
work the ring announcing or one no no
fights between like nypd versus zelda
yeah they still do it oh do they because
i was i was totally going to say no way
wouldn't you go to that oh that's
still do i think a lot of people who
don't like cops would go to that too
like you just get
each other it was a great night
lapd the fire department get involved in
it
um they used to have fights between the
cops and the marines down in pendleton
it's all good support you and all you
want to make sure it's all in sport
you want to make sure that someone will
get sued you know so some of these guys
would get up there and they'd start you
know the referees would stop the fight
or
and i challenged all of them hey hey you
don't like it
suit up get in the ring right you know
we hear these guys have real jobs they
have to go back to work tomorrow
yeah you don't want anybody to get hurt
you don't want anybody seriously hurt
yeah
that's badass though
once you get people together like that
they're out for blood once once you just
get that bigger crowd what else are we
doing
oh you guys gonna do voicemails yeah
that's good yeah
we have time oh yeah that was fun it
wasn't i liked it yeah throw on uh throw
on the headphones so we can hear the
goods
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah yeah george gotta slap those bad
boys on
there's a lot of cochinas out there
god bless those cochise i think you know
what god bless you nothing
all right you guys ready ready all right
first one off the top uh we got some
good questions in the realm of love so
here we go
hey what's up george gill and grant
triple g's and sebastian i'm from
baldwin park but now i live in utah
where these mormon potos have like six
wives you know
but
i just wanted to know how would you guys
feel about having more than one wife
like can you put bino handle out of that
ass or what let me know
there's dudes that have double families
though that's not that's not trying to
pretend not not the same as double
families double wives i can only handle
what i've got i don't want anymore
that's good enough for me and takes up
most of my time and the other time that
i'm not with her then i'm with my
friends so it's all good you do have a
nice balance of uh you still go to the
wvf i'm going to the vfw as soon as i
leave here today
straight down we got to go over there
one time hell yeah what are they doing
what are you guys doing can we crash sit
around and drink
and i'll stay there for maybe maybe
two hours max
oh wow so and then and it's about 10
minutes away from home so it's easy
where is it from city of industry
uh 60 hacienda you know where pacific uh
the hotel is big big golf course up
there yeah we shot we shot uh the comedy
get down tv show there okay well they've
got uh just maybe
a mile or two from there
right off the 60 freeway it's a great
place you'll see a bunch of old guys in
there
just drinking talking about it i love
that area i mean i like that place yeah
just just uh
just [ __ ] about old days and what we
did in the in the armed forces or what
we're doing now laughing those guys
golfer they're all too old i don't know
they no no some of them golf i'm sure i
just please go yeah that place is you
don't go offline no okay no i have i
have golf clubs in my garage but i don't
golf
not yet i feel like you don't know how
to weight georgia
let's go play one day over there at that
at that course i'll go over there and
stay overnight with that hotel i love
that place you'll you'll end up laughing
at me more than i laugh at you watch me
yeah it's fun though
those chords aren't easy too by the way
the ones it's in it at that point the
only thing i did at that course
i set out at one of the halls it was the
the hold of the tournament we're having
a homicide convention there so it was
closest to the pin and my job was to sit
in the golf course drink and see who got
closest to the pin that's all i did that
day measuring tape yeah that's great so
so what was the answer to that guy's
question no i can't get one much less
two i mean
yeah it's crazy have you been around and
i see more of these in hollywood with
time you've been around anyone with like
an open relationship or doing polyamory
or anything what's happening what's
polyamory polyamory just means you're
allowed you know as opposed to monogamy
which is like one poly is multiple so
you're allowed to be with multiple
people i remember the movie pollyanna
i don't think
i don't i think you have to be young to
be
in a poly but where you where you don't
where you can be with like three
different people i can only devote to
one right now that's enough like we're
older but i think it's and when people
are young they
you know right yeah like i i don't have
the programming for it it's certainly
not in my dna but like i'm i'm more or
less of the belief it's like look if
you're in a relationship and you two
agree upon something you know sure go
nuts that's what i said about that lady
that called into it asked if she was a
bhutan
she wasn't up with this she's the most
beautiful person
of this year that's right and until
people comes out with a beautiful people
of the year i'm gonna throw her [ __ ]
hater the pit and not and we don't have
to do details but uh you were you're
saying before the podcast that she
reached out to you she actually didn't
reach out to me god bless her she said
that she laughed uh first off she didn't
think it would air
secondly she really enjoyed my laughter
when i was laughing at her about it
but we were very easy on her she
understood and in fact
she broke it to her
this is a real deal yeah she ended up
breaking it to her husband he wasn't too
happy about it but they're talking about
it so
there's something going on she thought
that uh
george and myself were her surrogate
peels you know we're her uncles yeah so
real world effects to this stuff guys
and what was the uh the latest that she
said that the dude was in
allegedly kind of into it right yeah
well she said they're they're discussing
it they're in the discussion so
let's see what happens maybe she'll
after hearing this maybe she'll write me
back some more or i'll write back write
her back and yeah i i for one want to
hear as much of this saga as possible so
we can you know let's anonymize it but
uh you know
kind woman in the audience please keep
writing i would love to see please keep
sending this video right right messages
i'll reach out to her and see if we
can't talk about it openly you know
because i don't want to burn her i don't
want to yeah no absolutely we want to
respect that she trusts me right now
she'll trust you all the time you're a
trustworthy person not me on the other
hand
all right which other one all right uh
we got a little more lesson number two
i think aaron's gonna throw it up on the
screen we got eight one eight five three
three eighteen forty three do you leave
a voicemail for there's anybody out
there that wanna
be in my in my life
you know leave a voicemail yet we've yet
to get any of those do we like really
solidification
yeah nobody wants actually no no i take
that back we have gotten some some folks
are like oh here's hey george here's my
number i haven't passed those along i
can start if you'd like
all right we got more let's pass them
along let's get them to uh
to gail and see what gill picks for me
all right we got uh some more questions
here we go
yeah george
my name is ricky
and my lady man he likes me to um
have specs for her with my
ski mask on
and then
you know we enjoy it but lately
she's been putting her
in the extension of my cool
and i'm starting to like it what you
think about me what you think what's
going on
let me know
so sort of a two-parter there yeah you
were saying george it's a two-parter
i was a bird
that's sort of a two-parter what's the
first part let's run it again
yes where we lose you
have you lost your first part all right
we'll we'll hear this one from the top
it took a change in direction i didn't
expect that to be coming down the pike
field girls in there all right her name
is ricky
and my lady man she likes me to um
have sex with her with my
d mask on that that's
she's been putting her
index finger on my cool oh and i'm
starting to like it what do you think
about me what you think what's going on
with me i'm getting sugar in the tank
let me
sure you're know
it yeah yeah yes am i getting sugar in
the tank is that like is that supposed
to actually i actually it is
very latino i i i thought that uh
sugar in the tank was one of the best
greatest analogies that in spanish so
i thought it was one of the greatest
like you know
things but um i would say
you know so much is predictable so much
about sex yeah at some point it's
predictable hey
predictable
if he likes it go for it i mean if
anything bothering him and she likes it
makes her happy makes him happy
do it his finger or her finger
finger her finger up his cool yeah was
the no dude go with that order of
operations yeah yeah because you know
sometimes the kaka moves back
[Laughter]
yeah if you know do you do the problem
when you go to a restaurant and you go
you guys open and then everybody's like
we're closed
[Laughter]
there's nobody in there
they're closed you know so you don't get
you know
like oil you know the tank you put this
dipstick in maybe you get a little bit
of oil in there and you're like all
right it needs more oil
but uh you know not we don't think uh a
deviant or a pervert or anything like
that oh no just tell them to clean this
cool before they go
there you go
this is very
uh sexy
a very sex pile clean your kulito yeah
your sugar walls
your three sensations sugar oh my
goodness okay sugar water a man can have
sugar walls in my field's life i feel
like
uh okay uh we got another keeping these
in the
in the love for now another uh
well i'll just let him tell you
oh my god hi george
what's up
so here i'm 30 i live alone i have a
neighbor across the street
who is like this super milf she's hot
she's mexican she works out all the time
i see on her porch and her daughter's
also super banging
but
we're getting to know each other i'm
loving my apartment the thing is she's a
trump supporter
and i'm living right here in el cerino
and when i come over
we hang out
we have drinks and then
she just unloads
everything to me about her bitterness
toward immigrants how the community is
dropping because of just
[ __ ] just backwards trump rhetoric
so he sort of goes on for a while i can
keep playing it if you want to but
that's that's definitely the gist of it
right there you know what if he can't
get his bottle start
straight and dump her you know
would you say that if he can get hard he
should
regardless of her politician i don't
care
hit it if if that turns him off then
stay away find somebody else
hit on her daughter
but i tell you if you want to if you
want a clean way out of the one
relationship
yeah no but she said she's cool she's a
male she's not latino too right latino
trump supporter uh
yeah
hey they're out there there's no you
know the the craziest thing is to think
that because i'm not a supporter and you
are that's you don't you can hate me
because i'm not and i'm not going to
hate you because you are whatever
get out of the kitchen yeah yeah get
over it it's all about the sex you can't
get the take the heat that get some of
those little trapitos that clean your
hole the the little anal bleach wipes
there you go that's advisable
as well yeah
um there you go and there was a little
bit of it too he went on to say like
she's very into yoga and he felt like
all those principles of sort of like
peace and harmony are very opposite of
the trumpety stuff so very very
obviously tell him to stop shingando
jesus he's thinking about it a lot yeah
yeah
you know you go for it get over it go
for that ugly girl she lives next door
but i mean
who knows political beliefs i don't know
i mean i wouldn't
i wouldn't date a red hat but he's
thinking too much he's thinking too much
yeah you're just thinking too much yeah
yeah you're not going to marry her just
get back at him
all right there you go just get back out
that is the headline okay
let's see what else we get
tell them to talk to ricky oh actually
this guy uh-huh
yeah this guy likes to
ricky has it right
all right we got another one from the
same same gentleman here
oh my god hi george what's up what's up
me again
yo i got another one for you
so
i am a sex addict
and i belong to
and i've been going to 12-step programs
for
about three years now the same dude yeah
uh
well he's uh
he's el salvadorian but we're really the
only young guys in the
in the
group or in our what's considered a sex
action meeting
um
but like if it's at the point i posit
like it's at the point where you're
going to a meeting for it you're
definitely a sex no no but i mean
what's in between just a dude that hits
a lot of bangs a lot of chicks
a sex addict
yeah you could be afraid
yeah
i don't know
i think i mean i do think like medically
the definition would be if it starts to
if it's maladaptive if it's getting in
the way of other stuff in your life it's
like you know you have a hard time you
can't like he knows man because me
listen
i'm not gonna you know dis
disassociate the virus to the importance
of it but you know i do a lot of things
with this hand
and i'm still
he's not maladaptive
yeah all right
so if it gets in your way
yeah if it's starting to like interrupt
other healthy fun like maybe i try to
jack up and drive one time and i could i
could
i don't know how people hey that was in
the distance
that was in utopia disneyland even
though i could have thought it was in
one of those tea cups
i couldn't do it
i don't know if anybody can do it
because you have to focus on the road
yeah well it's hard to do it it's
certainly hard to do it to yourself
while you're driving like you could
maybe receive while driving then you're
or you're less developed wow you know
mom's mom
um that's what the four team freeway is
for
nobody
uh so again nobody's ever out there
he continues to go on for a little bit
but ultimately his his thing is uh so he
thinks he's he's a him and this other um
gentleman are the only two like
non-white dudes in this other like
they're in this recovery group for uh
sex edition it's in a 12-step program
and everyone else is a white dude and so
he's a little bit uh is it like a a like
you meet yeah it's basically that like
they have their own for pretty much
everything you can be addicted to
they'll have some sort of like 12-step
thing so it's basically a for sex
addicts exactly and so these guys are
like i don't know what to do like he's
not i can keep playing it too i don't
want to over no no
but it's like um
you know but it's a real issue yeah it
is and you know well let's hear some
more yeah let's let's get it from his
you understand what that is like
that basically everyone else other than
us is like this old white guy
and
i know that
this is it's like about recovery about
like healing or healing our wounds and
becoming better people
but
it's kind of hard to
find inspiration to be better when
the narrative the overall narrative in
the recovery in the recovery rooms is
from the perspective of a white male
and it's like how do i how do you bring
that up
and
or do we just start our own thing does
that make sense that they would be from
the white male's perspective i've got
i've got a basic question number one
from a white male perspective how does
he know how does he perceive it's his
perception
and perception is reality to the
perceiver but how does he how does he
think it's a what white man's
uh thing only and and second of all
i'm having difficulty believing this
whole story about being sexually
addictive when he just got got done
telling us on another tape that he's got
this milf right across the street and he
ain't talking about hitting it he's
complaining about everything she's doing
we're
were if there was a sex addict yeah he'd
be hitting him yeah so i i have
confidence maybe it's the politics that
turns him off but on somebody else it's
never an issue yeah if we're thinking
maladapte maybe he's like in the middle
of and i'm totally
guessing right but maybe he's in the
middle of like hating himself because he
can't stop sleeping with this woman and
couldn't disagree with her more he's
like you know that part is could be
tearing him apart beyond me trying to
get into his shoes here
who knows what that is saying stay in
the car is there more is there more uh
it keeps going
out let's hear it so how do we
go around saying that we're
um we're help we're we're
self-identifying sex addicts
and also
that
we need our own methods of healing it
sounds like i already know what i'm
saying but i don't think it's really
hard i don't i
how i mean what place is identifying a
sex addiction from a white man's point
of view it would just be
a colorless
behavior right i don't think you would
be saying you know they used to put
little monitors up and there were always
little white dolls you know if we were
growing up let's say these people have
been never looking like that but i don't
think in that in those classes that
they identify like therapy isn't i've
been going to therapy for 20 years to me
that guy doesn't make it about being a
white male it just makes it about you
know the issues that a person has not a
white person has
maybe that maybe
trouble getting the message and just
listening to what he's saying if he's
having trouble if he's having conflict
then maybe it's time to get to another
group
yeah that's a good idea you know as
opposed to staying where he's at because
he's not believing it and he's not
giving it a 100 percent maybe it's time
if it's one of those group therapy
things like hey you go somewhere else
yeah yeah
well i think that was he sort of uh
meanders a bit but i think that was part
of the question was like do i start my
own thing do i sure bring it up with the
group at large i don't know how much
money i think he should start his own
thing if it's that unique i think he
probably should probably start his own
thing right go find uh the
sexual addictive clinic by george lopez
wasn't that movie choke did you see that
movie choke was sam rockwell uh no i
don't think i did did you see it
is that is that based on like the chuck
palandwick thing yeah
yeah
and what what's the story there for for
people for he was they were sex addicts
right
yeah and they would choke each other
like
and that was what they would do to get
that story just a lot of kinky choking i
think it's a whole movie oh yeah
um i mean it's a real thing that's
that's sam rockwell like he's a
yeah he sees the girl in the
class and i think he's banging his
choking or learning some renaissance
fair or some [ __ ] i think so
yeah they work as reenactors in at
colonial williamsburg oh that's
hilarious even even better
i tell everybody's assignment and if
there was hope for him there's there's
hope for this gentleman i think so
yeah
there's a movie hey man watch choke if
you haven't seen it and hit us back i'm
gonna have to look it up
it's a good movie all right cool i'll
show you guys uh leave us you know uh
thanks for listening leave us a
voicemail eight one eight five three
three eighteen forty three i missed you
in this do we have two weeks off for now
just one week no just the one oh [ __ ] i
should have missed you in a week
you